gentlemen congratulations it's down to
the two of you decide who's gonna leave
here with the title of fortune fire
champion and that check for ten thousand
dollars now in this final round we're
sending you back to your home forges for
four days to build an iconic weapon from
history we want you to build this
oh
this is the elephant tusk sword
dating as far back as the 6th century bc
the mighty elephant was used during
warfare often armed with the fierce
elephant tusk sword this lethal weapon
featured a socket that connected
directly to the elephant's tusk the
double-edged blade was designed to
inflict massive destruction as an
elephant charged through barricades and
ranks of enemy soldiers throughout
history there is evidence of thousands
of elephant tusk swords being used in
battle however only four pairs of these
intimidating weapons still exist today
i've never seen anything like it i'm
trying to figure out how i'm even going
to construct this the terrifying feeling
is starting to set in again good luck
we'll see you in four days oh yeah
my name is matt weinberg i'm 38 years
old from knoxville tennessee i'm a
senior engineer and a part-time
bladesmith
i'm not normally a competitive guy but
for this i made an exception because i'm
here to win my adrenaline's already
pumping through my veins
and i'm ready for that challenge i've
got my width that i'm looking for but my
work piece might be a little too thin
i'm going to try and forge weld in a
mild steel medial ridge
so i'm going to get some mild steel and
try and forge weld that onto both sides
all right now we're cooking this sword
is meant for an elephant so the amount
of force that's going to go into the
blade is going to be off the charts we
want as even of a heat as we can get
check it with a magnet make sure that
we're at critical temp and then pull it
out drop it in my quench oil
good so far
i don't see any cracks all the welds
held up nothing blew apart
so far so good now just to make it look
pretty i'm gonna start off by securing
the blade to the socket i'm worried
about possibly overheating the blade so
i'm gonna have to take some extra care
to make sure the heat doesn't travel and
ruin the temper on the blade
let that cool off
doing a kind of test fit of the sword
perfect everything goes together as
smooth as silk this blade is crazy um i
never would have imagined myself making
something like this so i'm kind of
excited to see what kind of destruction
it does or maybe the sword blows apart i
don't know that's pretty sweet
my name is jaden simiski i'm 19 years
old and i started bladesmithing at about
age 15.
my entire life i've gotten in trouble
for two things playing with knives and
playing with fire
and so eventually it clicked in my mind
that i could make knives with fire
and it really just went from there
everything's looking good
i think that it's all welded up well i'm
going to start preparing to weld the
socket cap onto the blade if i do these
welds incorrectly i will end up with
cracks i could end up with the whole
blade basically just breaking off
the welds ended up great so i'm feeling
good about where i am
and today's mostly just going to be
making this thing beautiful so i'm going
to grind it like i would an axe i'm
going to do big convex edges because all
that extra meat in there will help
support the cutting edge itself that's
exactly how i wanted it it's way cooler
than i ever thought it would have been
and i'm happy with it at this point i
could show up and on the first day they
could snap in half and i'd walk away
happy i hope it doesn't though i do want
to win
bladesmiths welcome to the keel test
in battle these swords were attached to
elephants who just rammed across its
opponents find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do we're gonna
go hog wild on this ballistics dummy
jaden you're up first you ready for this
hell yeah let's do this
ah
i wasn't expecting his head to come off
all right james talk about your weapon
here
every thrust was deadly it went all the
way through what i do like is i can see
the damascus pattern on your blade there
jaden your elephant tusk sword it will
kill
that's all i wanted all right matt your
turns are you ready hopefully my store's
not irrelevant after this test
we're gonna have fun
all right matt it penetrates very deep
and on the way out it cuts
its weighted weapon right here that when
it thrusts see the hole right in the
middle of the ballistics dummy it
destroyed everything in there your
weapon right here it will kill thank you
doug
all right gentlemen the strength test
we've mounted your elephant tusk swords
on our battering ram here and i will be
attacking that armored soldier
all right jaden you ready for this yeah
let's do it okay
[Music]
that's terrifying
jaden i really have to commend you on
the artistry of this blade the low layer
pattern really pops the connections here
are all really beautifully done
and for this test that tip still has an
edge
everything is bright and tight and true
and nothing's changed
well done thank you
matt you're ready to roll absolutely
okay
[Music]
so matt your blade held up fine the tip
it's a little bit duller than what it
started out with but i wouldn't run my
finger down this edge so nicely done it
held up beautifully thank you
all right bladesmith we know your
weapons can kill and we know they are
strong now it's time to find out how
sharp your weapons are this is the
sharpness test the guillotine fruit
slice
we're gonna take your elephant tusk
sword release it and try to cut through
the fruit i want to see clean cuts all
the way through
dan you're up first you ready oh yeah
all right let's do this
[Music]
nice
all right jaden your edge here
cut all the way through cleanly
bottom line sir your elephant tusk sword
you'll cut
all right matt your turns are you ready
i'm ready
all right let's talk about your weapon
here the weight on this it drives the
cut all the way through your edge is
sharp more importantly sir
it will cut thank you
doug well jaden matt you guys both
perform exceptionally well during your
test but as you know only one of you
guys will be leaving here with the title
of fortune fire champion and today's
fortune fire champion is
jaden congratulations you won man matt
unfortunately that means you did not
come out on top today i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step out
i'm proud of the sword that i've turned
in they were virtually the same
performance which i mean yeah you too
and jaden's weapon he turned in a work
of art and i think he deserves the title
first thing i'm gonna do when i get home
kiss my wife and crack open a beer
well jaden that means you are today's
forge and fire champion you're gonna be
leaving here with a check for ten
thousand dollars man congratulations
thank you
i'm the newest fortune fire champion and
i'm really stoked about it how old are
you again 19. 19 years old that is
extremely impressive man i think what
i'm so bad at emotion
you